so Bren there's a sexy title but uh mmm
I know what you're thinking I don't have
a 17 car garage so what are you doing
for me all right
so where's my new jet I'm a noob where's
all my noobs about any noobs in here
thank you for your honesty
uh-huh yeah this is gonna help you get
going into the fun stuff so the painful
stuff you don't have to worry about it
till later all right so I'm trying to
help out the noobs I don't have any
professionals in here any tuners anyone
get asked to drop a performance engine
into a minivan from one of our customers
there we go
he knows the pain I'm trying to help you
get home at night so your wife and kids
can see you smiling face and then also
just for the average consumer right who
remembers the Volkswagen scandal
dieselgate then we remember that yeah
who's gonna help you actually like grab
Dad off your car and not have to spend a
lot of time learning how to look at that
data
it'll just computer blackbook here you
go you can say uh I don't really think
my card is doing what they sold me you
know like I was supposed to get a clean
diesel engine and now it's doesn't look
very clean so this is what this was this
code is for okay you know that I got it
the the 17 cars no one's got 17 cars
they're doing back to back to back but
that's what I'm talkin around and uh the
other benefit oh and this two it doesn't
just do cars okay I'll get into it a
little bit later but just real control
system anything where the computer is
sending a fixed packet link to another
computer and there's no metadata this
code is probably gonna help you do your
job or whatever you want to do whatever
you want to hack whatever you want to
play with okay so it's not just cars
all right so disclaimer I could do to
military these views are my own do not
reflect the Department of Defense the
United States Army the United States Air
Force or really anyone else other than
me so if I say something stupid it's on
me it's done on America right all right
so this is gonna be an
oversimplification and again I'm a noob
so please do not nuke me after this but
let's just categorize all the Nets into
two flavors all right we got vanilla
flavor first your general use network
and your goal here is I want something
flexible right this is the inner
for example I just want to be able to
add and remove hosts I want to be add
and remove links I don't have to worry
about really what the Nets doing I just
want to get onto it
and I want to talk to another end point
but you sacrifice something that nests
and guarantees you have no guarantee
your message is gonna get there you have
no guarantee when it's gonna get there
so I might have to resend I might have
to let them know hey this is this is my
IP what's your IP and there's a bunch of
metadata that's going along with this to
make sure that the message actually gets
there and it gets there in a reasonable
manner gets there all in one piece so if
you have a bunch of metadata at this
general use network and then you have
the exact opposite end of the spectrum
where I don't want to be flexible I want
guarantees when I press my break in my
car I want that break to work all right
I don't want to have a resend of me
pressing my break I want to just work I
want to work on time so I need a
guarantee that's gonna get there the
guarantee is gonna get there at a
particular time so a control network but
I'm willing to lose the flexibility on
the back end right so your car you're
not gonna add an extra wheel to your car
maybe
who's gonna add an extra wheel I
remember some psycho in here I don't
know but you're not so much worried
about that you want that guarantee of
timeliness and delivery guarantee and
this code is focused specifically on
control networks what you lose though is
if you want to look at the general use
network you've got all that juicy
metadata that you could be like alright
I've got this tag that tag you probably
don't even need to look at the actual
payload itself you could just look at
just a metadata but you don't have any
of that with a control network on the
car it's just bit here's 64 bits there's
another 64 bits there's no there's not a
lot of metadata there so a lot of people
have already done a lot of work waitwait
smart and me to help you play with
general these general use networks what
I'm gonna you know Brent stones gonna
call it general use network void the
interwebs smartphones Internet of Things
and just in addition to academia you
know you got Wireshark you've got snort
you've got all these things that will
plug into open source or while they use
things you got a bunch of academics with
20-pound brains cracking this problem in
particularly these last four guys I
think you can get this on the DEF CON
media server
if you want to nerd out and check out
some of this these last four guys I
thought did pretty good work with the
general use network you know the
automated reverse engineering but I want
to play of cars or I want to play with
medical devices where I want to play of
planes or a train or something else
there's nothing really there to help you
until now all right so let's let's see
what we can do I just want to get a
bunch of raw data off my control network
I want to click a button then boom it
spits out some useful actionable
information and maybe it might be off by
a bit or two but it's gonna give me 90%
of the way there
all right that's I just want the magic
to happen and that's what this code is
gonna do the code on the github repo and
I'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second but Brent what are you doing
on this slide like what is all this this
is like it's a chart right we call this
in militaries with no char like why are
you doing this to us like I did not
deserve this why all right there's a
couple thing of when you get on the
github don't be overwhelmed you only
need to worry about the pre-processing
everything's loosely coupled so you can
literally take a different protocol I've
already done this by the way you can
take it the completely different
protocol not change any of the rest of
the code the other 90% and it will
automatically reverse engineer that
different protocol for you so that's why
I'm saying it's not just cars all right
if you can sniff some debt off a medical
device and it fits the assumption that
every time some little widget on the
medical device is talking to another
widget and it always sends two bytes or
64 bits or something like that every
single time this code is probably going
to work for you okay
when I do a demo a little bit later I'm
actually gonna do three different
flavors of demo okay because we got we
got set up where I couldn't bring my own
laptop so I'm gonna do three different
flavors demo and make sure everyone is
fully satisfied with this presentation
the demo is going to be doing these
first two steps all right just to show
you how quick it can be and it's gonna
be a real time thing if you want to put
this on like an ARM chip or some sock or
something like that you could totally do
that and it'll be efficient enough
really efficient actually and then also
like how do we actually slice and dice
that bad boy I'm gonna specifically show
you some slides and like walk you
through the mentality of this this step
of slicing and dicing the data so you
can get out the actionable
formation and then there's gonna be a
bunch of more on the github again don't
be overwhelmed you just need to worry
about the first part all right so let's
walk through let's let's walk through
the logic not the code but the actual
logic of how do I slice and dice so what
do I mean by that let's say my dad has a
sentence this is a sentence exclamation
mark I've got four words one exclamation
point so I can slice and dice that guy
all right that's called lexical analysis
to math nerds and stuff like that and
then each little piece of that is a
token in that process is tokenization so
I want to tokenize my dad I want to
figure out where the boundaries are the
logical boundaries and then I want to
pull out each logically distinct piece
that the original equipment manufacturer
programmed into that chip to transmit
over the wire I can't just take the big
chunk all at once it's nonsense and then
there's this other process okay the
letters lexical analysis and then
there's semantic analysis saying let's
assume I've been successful I can
slicing and dicing correctly now I want
to understand right this one piece what
is this what am I looking at I'm on the
computer to help me figure that out
right by that earlier chart I showed you
where they all looked exactly the same I
want that kind of information and the
computer can figure that out for me and
as it does know so let's copy and paste
over to 64-bit payloads let's just
assume widget a on a car is talking to
widget be like the brake is talking to a
body control module or something and
sending six four bits six four bits over
and over and over again so many times
maybe it's synchronous maybe it's not
but it's just sending it over and over
again the exact same format the exact
same payload length I'm watching this
happen over time I'm recording it you
can just take all that these four bits
and then you can plot it or do whatever
you want it was probably gonna be
nonsense or you can do this slice and
dice operation this lexical analysis and
say alright let's grab bits zero to six
and just look at those and interpret
those is a distinct piece of information
and I'm gonna take bits seven to
something else I'm going to keep slicing
and dicing just like I did with a
sentence find the individual words and
then when I extract that this is a
natural example from a real car by the
way
you know if I looked a bit 16 to 232 I
get the vehicle speed and then if I look
at its 32 to 39 I get another copy the
vehicle speed but actually actually this
is in vehicle speed this is the RPM per
wheel and as you can imagine there's
four of these signals and then there's a
little bit of metadata at the front so
this one example of what this process
what the output of this would look like
okay so how do i how do I actually do
the slicing and dicing how do I do this
automatically how do I teach a computer
to do it all right let's say I'm looking
at the observations I've got in this
example I'm looking at 10 bit payloads
ok everyone following me and then I add
my first observation 0 1 1 1 0 0 0 0 0 0
and then some amount of time goes by and
I see the the microcontroller send
another 10 bit message 1 0 0 so on and
so forth so what you're seeing is from
top to bottom time kind of a lap saying
as I'm watching observations and then
from left to right I'm watching the bits
okay so the way that you can get a very
good educated guess on how do I properly
slice and dice this bad boys look for
the least significant most significant
bit no matter what they're doing unless
they're encrypting it or they
deliberately write some shenanigans to
reverse the bits and then put them back
together again you're gonna have a least
significant bit in the most significant
bit what happens is if I take a copy of
these observations I shift it by one
observation ok and then I XOR those two
copies what you get is how many times is
the bit changing between 0 and 1 how
frequently is it transitioning ok and
then if I take the sum of each column
and that resulting XOR then I get a very
good indication of where is my beliefs
and most significant bits embedded
within this larger payload alright so as
you can see 1 2 4 7 and then there's a
break and then there's another logically
logical piece of information 137 in this
case you know the right-hand three bits
was coming from 1 to 7 or something like
that and when you plot it it becomes
even more obvious especially to us as
humans right you can see a very definite
slope there's a little hill and then it
stops and there's another hill like ok
the OEM probably has two pieces of
information in this these
loads that it's sending now I can make a
pretty good educated guess alright so
how does that process actually work so
those of you familiar if like a
hill-climbing algorithm or like machine
learning folks in here you probably have
heard of that before
you do exactly that like I might I start
at the bottom of the hill or the top of
the hill I just keep going until I find
that least significant bit that's
transitioning a whole bunch of times and
then all sudden it'll be this sharp
drop-off that's probably the most
significant bit to another piece of
information embedded in that payload so
I'm just going to cut it right there
we're just gonna take however many bits
that is and then I'm going to put that
to the side bin number one I'm gonna
start over again
number two you know bit position 15 here
we go 16 17 18 I got you and then we're
going up to bid 32 and if we make
another cut put that bin number two
those just those bits I'm gonna look at
those later and what happens is when you
see that again this is a real world
example from a car I didn't give any
heuristics or anything to the algorithm
it really is just that simple and easy
in many times always but often times
it's that quick easy to teach a computer
just grab these bits and slice and dice
it that way now I've got that
information but Brent you said once I
slice and dice how do I know what kind
of information that is all right that's
true point it would the one of the folks
didn't in this auditorium right now has
listened to the full speech it literally
would take me two and a half hours to
explain this last part I'll say that to
like show off or anything just matter of
fact I don't want to put people to sleep
just go on the github after this if
you're interested if I forgot that hook
in you know and check it out we got a
document there it's very well documented
if you wanna know more about how to
actually identify like this is that type
of information versus that type of
semantic analysis well I'll just give
you one example right so I'm gonna show
you a bunch of examples as part of this
demo so I just want you to understand
what you're seeing in this case you got
the super micro print so if anyone's got
like eagle eyes you can maybe read that
probably can't but what I did is I just
threw this algorithm at the car it
looked at I think there is probably 120
IDs floating around the car at all all
craziness it grabbed slices from
different payloads all over the car
hey that that little slice looks like
that slice which looks like that slice
which looks like that slice and what you
get at the end of that is oh hey mr.
hacker like here's all the things that
look oh here's all the apples here's all
the oranges here's all the bananas that
I found in this car well I don't know
the full name but I can tell you these
things all look similar so you don't
have to do that that process anymore
okay they'll do it for you and oh by the
way in this this particular sample I was
actually able to request J 1979
diagnostic information is is my Prius
I'm conservationist I guess at least if
you ask other people in the military and
they got like the dually trucks like the
four wheels and everything I asked and I
was like hey give me vehicle speed while
I'm gathering this data and it turns out
this is exactly vehicle speed for when I
was going through this driving sample so
I won't get into the details of like how
can I claim accuracy with this stuff if
I don't have any truth data but what I
found is actually over 90 percent
accurate most of the time across all 17
vehicles we looked at so it might be off
by bitter - and for those of you that
have no you know work of this stuff you
know being off by a bit is kind of a big
deal but it will definitely get you very
very far along the process where you can
get home a night or you can believe that
your OEM sold you the features that they
thought they sold you or you could be a
newb and show off to your friends all
right so let's reverse engineer some
stuff so again I'm gonna break this demo
until like sort of three different parts
alright the first part I'm gonna walk
through it's just gonna be the slides
because I don't have my own computer
here I'm going to show you all 17 cars
is this sort of the output of the
semantic analysis it sliced and diced
and labeled and said these all look the
same and I'm gonna prove to you that I
didn't I didn't tweak it I didn't tune
it to any one car I just gave it certain
settings and then I let it go and every
single car I got something out the
second demo I'm gonna open it up to
questions or let people look at it but
honestly it's just like output saying
like this is how long things are taking
and then the third demo I'll hang out
either outside the room or over on the
side here with my personal computer I've
got it right here with this code loaded
up with some data samples if you just
want to talk about it or you want to see
it like actually being run in real time
more than happy to do that for you okay
so what you're seeing you're gonna see
to to like groups of plots what each
group is gonna be a car and again the it
sliced and diced it did the semantic
analysis piece saying these all look the
same and then it put them all in one
grouping for me I didn't do any work and
it said here you go enjoy okay so on the
left is gonna be vehicle on the rights
going to meet another vehicle and if it
says crop to fit that just means it
found a whole bunch of these and I'm
trying to make it so it's not micro
print for you all so I cut off a couple
of the signals that were on there so
that way we can sort of see it so on the
right hand side that just so you know
every single sample here I collected in
the same driving scenario so I had
people in a parking lot and then we we
drove down a small little hill and went
for about a three and a half mile drives
and kind of stoplights and a lot of
right turns and things like that and
then we came back to the parking lot and
stopped so you'll see it kind of goes
off and then probably comes to a stop
and goes up probably comes to a stop and
then a lot of times like so for example
this one on the left here vehicle three
if you've ever worked with can networks
controller area network some cars a lot
of times the OEM is like to put a
counter there just sort of keep track
and sort of like error checking in this
case it grabbed a bunch of counters from
vehicle three probably vehicle speed
from vehicle number four here I'll just
go through these on the bottom here on
the github I do have one data sample
again from my car my personal car that
you can just start jamming right away
just download it from github clone the
repo load up that data file and start
hacking again you can see like the
pattern sort of looks very similar again
I had everyone sort Drive very similar
on vehicle eleven it did have a little
bit of trouble I think is off by one bit
on that second second signal actually
yep and this is going around the hill go
around the hill
all right 17 cars though that was sort
of just proof number one proof number
two I'm gonna load up this video and
then if anyone's got a question I think
seems like a lot of people are real shy
so you can just come up here and ask me
if you don't want talking from the group
okay and then after that I'm more than
happy to show people on my computer
thank you very much
you